ah I see you over there
what are you doing you better not be
coming this way I got a flashlight hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome where are you guys where are you
at
hey guys welcome welcome to my new lit
setup Oh kill it sir yeah alright the
only difference is that it's better lit
that's literally the only thing going on
here but either way
welcome to the Brookhaven experiment and
the Brookhaven experiment is a demo that
I've played a while ago but now the full
game is out so happy go lucky for me so
I'm gonna play through the campaign
because I'm pretty sure that the demo
was about survival I mean the whole
games about survival I'm gonna die to
zombies but this one round I'm gonna
play the campaign I should probably have
the wrist straps on nah I like to live
dangerously
Time Square lab reserved Ettore okay
well bye um maybe I should do the Oh Oh
what happen to me oh this is Kali
maintain radio silence and look out for
hostels always check your six over what
maintain radio what silence whoo oh god
I gotta kill it with the kukri it's
called a kukri I know that from tf2 come
on me [ __ ] come at me huh kill it kill
it kill it
slay [ __ ] out how about Kiki go that
didn't work as smoothly as I thought it
was gonna hey neighbor
how you doing out there oh I'll be with
you in just a moment active and I can
see that you're in the old Fulton
machining place there's still enough
active GPS satellites to get the job
done I've got reports of a large herd of
hostels in your area I heard you say
over unholster oh okay well I'm ready
for this squeeze grip buttons to reload
you got a baby
I'm ready for this I should uh
it is now wave one I didn't quite get
the guy with makuu Cree but I boo
blam what did I got good-luck charm
well how does that help me huh my good
help Magus
legions of the Damned boy oh you are
dead oh hi hidey-hidey-ho heidy heidy
goodbye
what the [ __ ] boy there we go that's
more appropriate to it is that someone
behind me huh BAM
oh boy huh they seem to be coming very
slowly maybe I should handle you with my
kukri just reloading loose bullets no it
does not
aah thanks max Metz stick to listen-only
mode your voice will draw more of them
to your position listen only mode keep
moving that tracker will let me know
you're still on mission wait lists
almost down so take care of any
remaining hostels in that place and get
out of there wait what was that him my
voice
you mean the lyrical softness of my
booming voice is gonna ah what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] oh my god I was not
prepared for that what the [ __ ] well we
got Dean Rea
can I mention that this okay but can I
mention that this Oh can I mention that
this doesn't work very well I'll try
that one I don't need help
what am i a scrub whale Moo defender
Spectre new para none of these help me
home I am mm bolt up off upgrade oh the
different upgrades okay throw bowl
upgrade bolts on upgrade I can get
nothing I'm good okay so there's a lot
more customization options and I imagine
that they've done a lot more polish on
getting this game up and ready hello
friend you're going to be joining me
you better not all back off Big Momma
huh I should know that I'm incredibly
intimidating when I'm looking up at your
crotch oh no oh no oh no oh no [ __ ] off
there we go
now with more impressive hope I am
mm-hmm what's that you want to have a
conversation
no and no what are you doing why are you
doing I don't think so reloading hmm do
I hear the snippy step ease of some
losers come at me scrubs come at me Oh
No
you came and died who's that over there
mm nope hey uh how about a big nope man
I'm too good what the hell I didn't know
what that was I got the specter dude
come here I got something to tell you
fie on them I got the specter bra from
Town Square you'll see the lamp aha hair
will light your way time square huh yeah
really
oh I could do a little bit of that I
haven't been very mobile I can move
around a little more
what do you want from me huh
Jesus I guess I'm done with that well so
far so goo I'm doing great
is everything still recording gosh I
hope so if it's not I'm gonna be so sad
let me just double check BRB ooh are we
done
whoo I did it I can't it guys I did it
oh boy oh hey it blew its load with that
one jump scare and it wants to give me
oh we're back here okay good it's better
than the turn it on don't turn that
flashlight on unless you need it okay
conserve your battery oh it's a lot
darker than the last time they were here
No ooh the specter lightweight high rate
of fire well I don't really need a lot
of rate of fire um it's got the exact
same fire power though so we're pretty
close enough that doesn't matter all
right I get any of these choose upgrade
not locked buff whew ah I like the sound
of that nope how about this all right
well I guess I just have that stun
grenade who needs that
what do this oh I like that oh look at
you
oh you dangling [ __ ] uh-oh you adorable
little yeah Jade little piece of [ __ ]
clear a path and be ready for anything
what am i doing clearing a path where
Who am i clear path from zombo's does
Dumbo want to fight Oh huh huh hello
and bam woohoo laser sight huh I don't
need a laser sight for these [ __ ] I
know exactly what I'm sighting and I can
hear you all creeping up from behind me
boink
nope yeah there we go what's that over
there oh boy oh boy oh boy
hey who's there who's there hey and
bingo was his name-o
and deado was his name-o there we go oh
there we go
she's um you [ __ ] coming at me like
that
what boy all right we got him was that
the last one huh huh can I do my happy
dance turn this off save this a little
bit I got a laser say but I don't even
know if I'm gonna need it
I'm so accurate um excuse me what do you
think I am bad sigh oh not I didn't even
need this what does this crumb I guess
it doesn't have a battery anymore
because they realized how stupid that
was but I was already dead accurate am I
gonna have any problem with this the
answer's no who's running hey shouldn't
have given me the laser sight bruh
hi I am dead anybody else someone's over
there oh do I see you in the darkness
and the darkness I get ya
ah I got him he didn't mean for any of
this to happen we were just curious how
dangerous is it to pig whoo Oh maybe a
little bit trying to judge by anything
in the city and there's a lot of
destruction going on here maybe that
thing mmm
come at me bro come on me little bit who
do we go oh hello I'll be with you in a
moment please just don't bother me right
now
Hey all right so far so goo hello there
we go what did that guy have armor on
his head or something
all right I don't need this boink and
we're done
I'm doing great I'm doing wonderfully
indoors you only have to worry about
hostels that can fit through doorways
outdoors they better have enough ammo
for the bigger specimens what are you
talking about bigger oh oh oh boy here
we go
are you want somebody you ain't gonna
get none of me where's my where's my
throwable where's my throwable hang on
got to be a throwable here 90th Roble
there we go
proximity mine yeah oh honey that ain't
far proximity enough oh oh
dad I didn't need two of them I thought
I would get into that building you need
to make your way to the basement and get
one of the backup generators going the
generator won't provide enough power for
more than emergency lighting but it will
let you use the computers in the
observatory
okay PAP is clear it's time to move ah I
don't know about time to move oh geez
all right we're doing pretty good not
bad I kind of shifted off on my center
it doesn't require me to move a whole
lot I remember it being a lot more
stressful than the other one but let's
see how it is in the lab I'm not sure
I'm not sure how far until like I'm not
sure how long this game is but let's see
like see what we got at least lab
basement oh that's good hopefully it's
more spoopy cuz I've seen all this [ __ ]
before the first area was good with that
jump scare ooh this is spooky looking
woo me likey Marky like oh [ __ ] Oh can't
get your current oh yeah you found it
oh oh I got a bad feeling about this
I got four areas lots of places to be
ambushed I'm gonna die oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
whoa [ __ ] this ain't good whoa [ __ ] whoa
oh there's gonna get something BAM [ __ ]
is gonna get a whole lot of something
whoo whoo that [ __ ] okay come on bring
it on
give me some heart oh boy oh boy
I hear him oh yeah I hear him coming
whoa [ __ ] okay we got it we got it we
got it we got it we're good boy okay
we're good
whoo Nellie oh oh oh okay so far so goo
whoa I can tell this is gonna get real
bad if I was playing survival mode in
this one whoo boy whoa Nellie
whoa Nellie hmm oh hey I don't want to
wait around for those guys and start
chasing me I want to hit him herd get
him fast and heard what how you're not
dead there we go whoo okay that's gonna
be a doozy that's gonna be a real doozy
I keep checking this door cuz I'm
paranoid that someone's gonna come
barging through there's no one else here
but you never know there's always a risk
I'm gonna try to do this one with a
flashlight just to make it interesting
cuz there's plenty of fire I'm gonna go
back to my old gun the defender and
hopefully you can give me something good
what do we got oh now we're getting
spoopy Oh an hour getting major spewpa
jump in here I hear you ooh
ooh I see you okay hey buddy oh this is
scary
like oh [ __ ] no joke whoa too close too
close too close
oh God Oh Nellie okay
oh geez oh geez ohms oh Jesus
okay here we go take that look away oh
oh that's huh oh [ __ ] ah okay holy
goddamn Wow
oh jeez okay he did I'm about to be dead
I should have just been shooting him
from the get-go that flashbang did
nothing
everything's tinted red that doesn't
mean good oh boy
there's one hell of a recoil on this gun
whoo-hoo-hoo whoa okay I come at me bro
oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy come on mama oh ma reload reload
damn it well the Wild West up in here
whoo I can't see a goddamn thing
we were whoo the limitations of
spaceflight imaging technology beingness
late work having seen as much as he
could three-dimensional University okay
how far through the fog could we pierce
could we see the past the future could
we see entirely I'm imagining that you
figure that [ __ ] out which is a good
thing oh boy oh okay we're good whoo
Nellie whoo that was thousand ten no
joke that got really scary there for a
second
like I haven't played a vibe game in a
while but having a looming like right
here in my face it it's good I can't
wait for this get better okay I got to
do help this time cuz I'm some kind of a
Boyles oh man those a Molotov cocktail
available in that one damn it all right
I'm going back to the specter because I
need the higher fire rate because what
happens is the gun the gun itself kicks
back but this time I'm not gonna do a
laser sight I'm gonna do others I'm just
gonna do standard I like to get myself
challenges still no still no uh still no
uh flashlight it's more interesting that
way Oh Nellie whoa okay starting right
off are we we're yet down there oh I see
you
okay that guys down there yo who did he
jobs or did you get knocked to the side
there for a second come on there we go
oh this is much more interesting without
the laser sight I actually have to aim
oh do I hear oh boy okay got him just a
matter of putting as many bullets in him
as possible there we go alright so far
so goo would do I hear the thumping
thump of another oh hey hi friend whoa
hey buddy okay we got it
whew man I don't even have any time to
be sassy about this getting a little
panic inducing I haven't seen any other
upgrades like blue boxes I've been
looking for him but I don't see him what
are they doing to me oh they're not
giving me what I need and what I need is
a lot of help a lot of help
Waddell oh you're getting too close for
me whoa boy oh boy oh boy gets get dead
whoa jeez
Oh Nelly ho Nelly Miami Miami labor
reload there you go okay sunlight beam
shows me the emergency lights are okay
you got it baby
I'm here for you woah
we did it okay we did it Wow holy [ __ ]
oh my god huh hey I apologize for not
being very puck talkative these rounds
I'm just in a tizzy about getting
through this without dying which I'm
doing better at but I need more guns
what I need I need a lot more gun I'm
gonna get him though all right I think
that's the last level the observatory
let's try let's do it I'm down I'm down
the clown just do it
ooh okay hello
where why is it back there well that
better not be what what why that way why
is that the front now but I needed huh
well you're gonna see a lot of my ass in
this round
sorry about that unless that's what you
wanted don't know Rama this is Kali I've
got you logged in good work I'm opening
a tunnel to that PC our signal being so
weak there's no way I could download
hundreds of gigs of data remotely but I
can run that machine from here and
download the relevant data to your drive
ah stay safe while I get the transfer
going stay safe well what is that up
there okay the data transfer has started
there's a lot to copy so you're going to
have to defend against hospitals great
good to know from behind I got to shoot
him from behind my head
blam from back BLAP BLAP BLAP BLAP BLAP
okay I'm gonna get it what do you want
when do you want it Deb
well it is dark without that flashlight
whoo hello buddy
got you
oh whoa who's who's big where's big I
hear big whoa where the hell is big am I
losing my goddamn mind I hear big whoa
boy whoa boy I hear big down there where
the [ __ ] I'm losing my goddamn eyes whoa
aah oh yeah oh boy oh boy I see you down
there I see you what yeah oh my god oh
jeez oh jeez oh jeez
I got him head clean off
Wow okay I did not even know I did not
even know that front was an option who
is okay so there are from the front so
you won't see as much of my ass as you
wanted to see but you're gonna see a lot
of it if I could just get another gun
I'd be really [ __ ] happy you boy okay
I'm gonna get the laser sight again
because it's hitting dicey in here and I
don't want to be messing around with
nothing
whoo it's bad enough I can't even see
with the flashlight let alone without
but it newly hatched ambitious little
things
don't let them gang up on you what the
babies what are you talking about the
babies that doesn't make any goddamn
sense the last time I saw Sami babies he
was dead bruised that doesn't sound like
a baby oh boy we worried would you oh
geez where'd you go I thought they were
Moria hey buddy
oh the laser sight is so much better
than actually having skill what all
right someone comes down that hallway
again
lock him up [ __ ] him up
we're your Abra I don't see you were you
at I know you're down there oh oh oh I
see you I see you now that's someone
else oh oh geez no BAM [ __ ] BAM [ __ ]
where you at
got you hang on got you okay got your
whoo that doesn't sound good
oh I see some whoa hey babies babies I
don't want to see you up close thank you
very much I don't want to see nothing up
close my um [ __ ] whoo who the heck oh
[ __ ]
who did that
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Wow baby execution
style execution style who's coming from
where nice got you nailed you in the
face move you in the face [ __ ] off right
now moves you in the face
boo you're on such a good shootin you
look at me now the people in the pies
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] up
with ya [ __ ] I thought someone over
there
[ __ ] ah still don't see any goddamn
upgrade boxes wait
hey nice okay so they're hidden I don't
know why I expect them not to be hidden
hello ah good enough for me right wow I
did it huh oh man
whoa get this Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam it's
somewhere down there
Oh plenty old a narrow opening into
another oh shut up people
we called it uh-huh but is quantum
physics old you cannot observe without
affecting the observed ah you saw we
stared at too long for apparently it saw
us back are more that people into a
gateway at least I hope
Gateway tour that people that implies it
can be closed okay alright then tore
that peephole into a goatse hole if you
know what I'm talking about
well then you shouldn't have dabbled
with things beyond your comprehension
hello and if I know anything about
quantum physics that's not out quantum
physics work with what you described
hello we're at work we're there yes okay
got him who's up there huh who goes
there
I need to save my battery [ __ ] whoa some
down there whoa good thing I got this
extended mug [ __ ] whoa what do you mean
they just hatched that would like coming
down that whoo that would imply that
they are growing these things which
isn't very good
oh boy
getting dicey Wogan desi boy babies
babies babies
[ __ ] babies babies babies whoa whoa
well just [ __ ] babies jeez um get him
off my shoes okay cool I'm almost out of
battery retain a good thing can't hide
from me well where do you go there we go
well it is moderately terrifying baby
baby baby baby [ __ ] babies whoo geez
thought I heard some tiresome some
coming up there okay give me a goddamn
break oh I have a breather what was that
[ __ ] I hear noises outside of my house
all right we're good Oh probably only
one more round to go after this and then
we're done shut up I don't like the
sound that with that with that oh geez
with that oh hey little bugger all right
you want some huh
goddammit you're tough oh crap Oh
[ __ ] bastard [ __ ] [ __ ] you who's
there
what the [ __ ] I'm in trouble
but you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you man
oh god I can't see anything oh geez I
see you little buggers ah oh oh this is
bad
Oh is bad how much better okay I got
plan I'm leaving battery on can't see a
goddamn thing okay
woo [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't silent you need sound here here
good
the transfer is complete and I'm logged
off Oh judge that flash drive is now the
most important thing that exists in the
world you must get it to me no matter
what it takes
okay I got it streets are overrun but
that servitor you should have a shaft
next to a storm drain follow the flames
we have to spin it you telling me that
you telling me that I got to go to a
sewer next you telling me 100% that my
next level is a sewer cuz I don't like
sewer levels in horror games hoary [ __ ]
alright well if that is the case then I
guess I'm I'm continuing going on let me
let me see how many levels there are
first and I'll be right back
cuz that will evaluate cuz I've been
recording for about 45 minutes now oh
hello oh I'm front and center again
guten guten morgen collab basement ok I
did basement did the observatory wait a
minute wait are you kidding me Oh next
don't be good ah there's a lot more okay
and then next oh there's tons more okay
so I'm not even close to done with this
so anyway I'll leave it at that it's I
mean it's technically gonna be more the
same but I imagine that this time goes
on they're gonna unlock more and more
monsters so I'll leave it up to you if
you guys want to see more of this game
let me know in the comments below I
really need your opinion on this if you
want to see this game fully play because
it's a lot of fun so I'm more than happy
to play it but let me know down
I'm below thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye oh yes hi
whoops
ha yeah